welcome to this video playing the Blitz
kicker from the Netherlands and I think
I had looked this up my lesson a min now
okay hurt so he's taking on your form
and I cannot really go for this tricky
variation maybe i can i can try again to
go for this so i was very his playing
very quickly okay we have got the Rubens
Rubenstein French so many lines named
after Rubenstein me one of the most
influential players in terms of opening
theory a long time and lots of his
concepts are still very popular and and
developed today so should I I could I
could try that go for for this Queen
maneuver to them to the Kings side
not sure if it is really good but he
hasn't castle yet and probably he won't
in the near future I don't know it looks
dangerous we should be five intent and
thanks I just developed Bishop g5 roop
do you wanna be on see what my pieces
can do
yeah but okay yeah maybe he's
threatening to take
it's not threaten them direct sense but
ok I can easily get the porn back with
some certainty a slightly better
position ki threatened to Queen d5 would
she which he attended to if you move to
the right a bush on page seven
once in a while a simple trick can be
can be effective it's not so easy for
him to develop now I also have the
bishop before idea and then c 4 i'm just
much better develop Jim
I don't really know what you should play
I'm also threatening c4i taking on d 8
which is also quite a substantial threat
okay here be sure before I am cannot
move the night and I'm threatening c4
not quite sure what is playing actually
also just retina bishop d5 I mean Bishop
g5 root d525 when the house cannot move
the rook maybe I'm winning here awesome
trick some trick like be 5v5 Bishop g5
Bishop d7 some stuff like that this
could be possible
yeah but I can just take it what are you
doing between the eight maybe
should I go 95 first and then see for
maybe pattern Bishop g5 quindi eight
I also have them look II 6m Bishop g5
quindi a drug is six rook t5 Queen d525
this Ruby a check yeah come get this
shirt should really win
the important thing is that rook t5
Queen d525 does Ruby a check this is
what check is important black resigns
yeah but i think it was it was some more
than one solution um I think it's just
to win here yeah computer Louise plus
five plus four or something yeah I
interesting it it went downhill really
quickly here yeah be 5v5 is the only
move that vaguely keeps the game going i
mean i can just take it it's a pawn but
it's not a piece this is really the only
move everything else pretty much losses
and here there's also 95 winning but
this should win as well on hmm but it's
not yeah also convincing computer gives
this as a bit a bit tougher it only
leads to two extra phones yeah like that
check but okay then then the other move
95 is even better I mean I saw that this
is one possibility one justice just the
same the rook is unprotected on d6 the
difference but ok this is this is just a
win as well but not more than one point
per game alright thanks for watching